from the director of the King Kong
Universal Studios ride comes a film
adaptation of the overly dense nerd by
balls that employed an entire nation
when an even fagina eye awakens it's up
to this Hobbit and this fantasy boy band
to destroy its jewelry prompting these
unlikely heroes to embark on an 11-hour
New Zealand tourism commercial rife with
walking
roeme
hi gain
more walking
and strolling join our heroes as they
face worthless armies of middle-earth
all vying for the most powerful object
in the world the one ring to rule them
all which does absolutely nothing
besides turn you into an invisible crack
addict the
a quest so long these hobbits will need
to be carried by horses carried by orcs
carried by trees carried by eagles and
carried by hobbits I don't carry it for
you but I can't carry you lead
characters whose names are so
complicated only a linguist could
remember like and of Bilbo so young
Saruman Aragorn son of Arathorn Emir
Emily son of Gloin scallop Sandra's
bring a warm tongue Legolas I'm doing
you Sam from the award-winning visual
effects team that launched the career of
one man who must now wear skin tight
spandex and face dots for the rest of
his life comes a movie bursting with so
much manly compassion you'll think
you're watching Brokeback Mountain Dew
a tale that will strive to prove that
people of all walks of life can work
together as long as they're all white
seriously even when they die they come
back whiter and an adventurer where
every lead character faces constant
mortal danger but only Sean Bean dies
gee haven't seen that before
starring homeless magneto vegan Morton
Stein Gwyneth Paltrow Morningwood Zagal
Athena kanakas fat Rudy Game of Thrones
reference Harold and Kumar clear eyes
and Lindsay Lohan the Lord
that took so much of Peter Jackson's
life he didn't want it to end
prompting five completely separate
endings that go on and on forever making
it really hard to hold in your pee the
Lord of the Rings trilogy a film with
such fake emotional stakes Gandalf will
sacrifice himself for his friends only
to somehow come back to life making it
not really a sacrifice and a story where
the protagonists can't win their own
battles without convenient ghost armies
living trees and magic eagles the Lord
of the Rings trilogy
I can't believe we're only halfway
through this Peter Jackson nerdgasm
Happy Hanukkah screen junkies make sure
to check out our trailer for Jewish elf
oh and if you think I sound different
read the description below and don't
forget to leave a comment with something
you'd like to hear me say in my epic
voice they're taking the hobbits to
Isengard these pretzels are making me
thirsty my hugs my hugs my lovely lady
loves I got 99 problems but a [ __ ]
ain't one